if we could
we step back to the big profound
philosophical
both tragic and beautiful question about
age
how and why do we age is it uh
from an engineering perspective he said
you like the biological machine
is that a feature or a bug of the
biological machine
it is both a bug and a feature uh
evolutionary speaking we
only live as long as we need to to
replace ourselves efficiently
if you're a mouse you're only going to
live two and a half years three years
you're probably going to die of
starvation predation freezing in the
winter
so they they divert most of their
resources to reproducing
rapidly but they don't put a lot of
energy into preserving their soma which
is their body
conversely a baleen type of whale a
bowhead whale in particular will live
hundreds of years
because they're at the top of the food
chain and they can live as long as they
want
so they breed slowly and build a body
that lasts we're somewhere in between
because we've you know we've really only
just come out of the savannas where we
could be picked off by
a cat we were pretty wimpy gone back six
million years ago
so we we actually need to evolve quicker
than evolution will
and that's why we can use our oversized
brains
and intuition to give us what evolution
not only didn't give us but took away
from us you know we're pathetic look at
our bodies
these arms if any of us even the
strongest person in the world went in a
cage with a chimpanzee
the chimp could knock that person's head
off no question so we're pathetic so we
need to engineer ourselves to be
healthier and longer lived
so getting to aging we we can do better
right whales do way better we're trying
to learn how whales do that
and if you ask really anybody in the
field now
professor they'll say there are eight or
nine
hallmarks of aging which are really it's
a it's a
word for causes of aging so that you
probably have heard of some of these
your listeners will have
a loss of telomeres the ends of the
chromosomes like their little
uh ends of shoelaces that kind of thing
they get too short cells stop dividing
becomes senescent
they they become um they put out what
are called mitogens that cause cancer
and inflamma inflammatory molecules
that's another aspect of aging
cellular senescence another one is loss
of the energetic so mitochondria the
battery packs
wind down uh there's a whole bunch stem
cells
uh proteostasis well these are our
achilles heels that i'm talking about
that are common amongst old life forms
really but if you wanted
me to jump to the chasers to where what
is the upstream
defining factor if we boil it down what
do we get
so most biologists would say you can't
boil it down it's too complex
i would say you can boil it down to an
equation which is the preservation of
information
and lost due to entropy i.e noise
and that is the basis of my research
it originally came out of discoveries in
yeast cells where
i went to mit in the 1990s you studied
bread
i kind of did i studied the uh the
makers of bread
a little yeast called saccharomyces
cerevisiae which at the time was
one of the hottest excuse the pun uh
organisms to work on yes
but they we figured out in the lab why
yeast cells get old
and found genes that control that
process and made them live longer
which was an amazing four years of my
life
one of those genes had a name with an
acronym
sir2 now the two is irrelevant
the s-i-r is important and the most
important letter out of all of those
three
is i which stands for information
silent information regulator number two
when you put more copies of that gene in
just put in one more copy
the yeast cells lived 30 longer and
suppressed the cause of aging which was
the dysregulation of information in the
cell
and then so fast forward to now i've
been looking
in humans and mice because they live
shorter and
cheaper to study where the loss of
information
in our bodies is a root cause of aging
and i think it is your boldness in
viewing biology in this way
is fascinating because that also leads
to a kind of
uh it's almost like a allows for a
theory
of aging like like you could boil it
down to a single equation and it leads
to a perhaps a metric
that allows you to optimize aging sort
of in the fight against entropy
to figure out which mechanisms like you
said the the silent information
regulator which mechanisms allow you to
preserve
information now without like without
injecting noise without
without creating entropy without
creating degradation of that information
for some reason converting biology
which i thought was mostly impossible
into an engineering problem
feels like it makes it amenable to
optimization to
solving problems to creating technology
that can
whether that's genetic engineering or ai
it makes it possible to
create the technology that would improve
the
the degradation of information and aging
is there more concrete ways you think
about the kind of information we want to
preserve
and also is there good ideas about
regulators of that information about
ways to
prevent the distortion the degradation
of that information
right so that we have some information
regulated genes in our bodies we have
seven of them
uh certain one through seven they're
called and we found in in mice
one way to slow down the loss of
information is to just give more of
these
um to upregulate these genes so we we
made a mouse that has more of this 31
gene
turned it on and that slowed down the
aging of the brain
and preserved their information now what
information am i talking about you might
ask
well again you can simplify biology
there are two types of
information in the cell primarily the
one we all
read about and know about is the dna the
genome and that's base four
uh information atcg the four chemicals
that make up the various
sequences of the genome billions of
letters
and that also degrades over time but
what's been fascinating
is that we find that that information is
pretty much intact
in old animals and people you can clone
a dog one of my friends in la just
cloned his dog three times
so this is dual right that means that
the genome can be intact but
what's the other type of information
it's the epigenome
the regulators of the genetic
information
and physically that's really just how
the dna is wrapped up
or looped out for the cell to access it
and read it
so it's similar to an excuse this
analogy
but it's a good one a compact disc or a
dvd
those pits in the foil are the digital
information that's the genome
and the epigenome is the reader of that
information and in
in a different cell you'd read different
music different songs
different symphonies and that's what
gets laid down when we're
in the womb and that gives makes a skin
skin cell forever a skin cell and not a
brain cell tomorrow
thank god otherwise our brains wouldn't
work very well but over time what we see
is
that the brain cells start to look more
like skin cells and the kidney cells
start to look more like liver cells and
they what we call
x differentiate this is a term that we
use in my lab but isn't yet
widely used but we needed a term to
explain this and that those
that process of x differentiation the
loss of the reader
of the the cd or the dvd uh we
liken that to scratches
on the dvd so that the reader cannot
fully access the information
now we can slow down the scratches as i
mentioned we can turn on these genes we
can even put in
molecules into the cell or even eat them
and turn on those
pathways which which my father and i
have been trying to do for about a
decade
to slow things down but the question
that i've had
is is there a repository of information
still in the body
because anyone who knows anything about
the loss of information or even has
tried to copy a cassette tape or
photocopy or xerox anything knows that
over time you
you lose that information irreparably so
i've been looking for a backup copy
inspired largely by claude shannon's
work at mit as well in the 1940s
his theory mathematical theory of
communication is just brilliant and so
i've been looking for what he called the
observer
which is the backup copy we today might
call that the tcpi pro
tcp ip protocol of the internet that
stores information in case it doesn't
make it to your computer
it will fill in the gaps and we've been
spending
about the last five years to try and
find if there really is a backup copy in
the body
to reset the epigenome and polish those
scratches away
that's incredible so finding the backup
so whenever there are too many scratches
pile up you can just write a new version
like write the not every new version but
go to the backup and restore it
right that's really all we're talking
about it's not that hard
once you know the trick and for people
that actually remember
like dvds and scratches on them how
frustrating it is
that that's a brilliant metaphor for
aging
and then the the reader is uh
is the thing that skips and then it
could destroy your experience
the richness of the experience that is
uh listening to your favorite song
right but in biology it's even worse
because you'll lose your memory your
kidneys will fail you'll
you'll get diabetes your heart will fail
and we call that aging
and age-related diseases so it's it most
people forget that
diseases that we get when we get old are
80 to 90
caused by aging and we've been trying to
fix things with band-aids after they
occur
without even generally talking about the
root cause of the problem
you